The language that you will learn in order to talk to the computer, is called
Java. The name Java was chosen for fun. Many programmers drink lots of coffee.
And some people call coffee, Java, because of the island of Java. They grow
coffee. Whatever. We've chosen Java, for a number of reasons. Java is very,
very popular. There are millions of programmers who are familiar with Java and
who use it every day on the job. Java is as programming languages go, pretty
simple for the most part. There are a few rough edges because Java was not
designed as a training wheels language for students. It really is a real word
programming language. But, that's okay. Java is safe. And, that's great for
students. When you make an error, you'll get a very clear indication of what
went wrong, and it'll be easy for you to fix it. And finally, Java is very
useful for the kinds of everyday tasks that you might encounter. Processing
text, processing images, dealing with the web. In this course, you will learn.
To use Java in such a way that you can simplify your own work. So again, what
is Java? Java is a programming language, a language to write instructions for
the computer that is popular, simple, safe, and useful. Let's get going to
write some programs in Java.